welcome to this video playing avildsen
palencia that's really a person no I'm
what I'm trying to say that this real
name Wilson palencia that's an IM from
Columbia okay so maybe this line this
tricky sideline that I play sometimes
quite often catches people unaware as a
three takes takes be six but the long
thing here the relatively long think
points to yes play something else just
no idea 3 i'm still trying to play with
the bishop to a 6 trying to trade my
bishop okay it's Bishop f4 it's not not
a very common way to to set up the
pieces there Queen B 5 I have 96 it's
not a problem I wonder hmmm how to play
here you might play 92 and ask my [ __ ]
Bishop some rather inconvenient
questions but I can go naija six and
possibly back ok that's it might be it
might be all right yep back
he maybe goes h form maybe I know it
looks a bit strange they are not playing
c5 but c5 is some sometimes a tricky
move because I'm pretty much behind in
development and if I go see five him
sometimes white is going with c4 and
open it opens up the hole and the whole
Center quickly it's often a better idea
i'm not sure but it's often a better
idea to delay them with liberty and this
type of position and only play it when
numb when you are reasonably sure that
your pieces are all in play
95 m I don't know some of this name
Wilson palencia I always have not quite
sure why but I'm always I always think
about the particular movie scene I
always have to think of Nestle leslie
nielsen in the in the the naked gun when
the air is some singing the national
anthem of the of the United States and
the end of the movie antes he's some guy
he's impersonating a famous singer and
the name is enrico palazzo and some i am
palazzo and palencia always have to
think about this movie ok so what about
this he might go fy5 in this position
right ok when f4 I probably need to play
ff5 yeah yeah he wants to wants to use
his rook there may be swinging I'm a bit
passive here thats it's clear
maybe f6 I know he will take anyway I
guess takes takes bishop age six Luke f7
Jim I wouldn't mind an endgame here but
i'm not sure that i seared the night
against the bishop is sister is quite ok
not sure if root this is actually
leading to something his pressure on the
e-file is quite quite annoying
Jeff 98 it's not exactly a dream
scenario just the text there okay but
now Bishop be eight okay that doesn't do
that but let's prepare possible rookie
73 f sevens just be flexible about it
night Jim Knight to f5 would be would be
quite good if I get this end but not
sure if I do the only relatively good
news is that is taking quite some time
there yeah f5 Bishop h4 unfortunately m5
bishop age form
9 p-7 rookie six I cannot somehow second
a sacrifice a pawn f5 bishop age 497
rook is six take everything off rook g6
eyes got this bloody check their check
on the age he threatening a five though
that's definitely end up in the position
ah what an awful position ok let's it's
maybe still try to give him the spawn
check now yes rook f6 just picks up this
bloody pawn ah what a shame wanted of
course a night good wanted to go to e4
you with the night time morning now I
have to have to keep keep this gym what
is shame I get in 1964 I'm still kind of
hanging on so I'm not giving up not yet
okay that didn't help him a lot check
here he may be gained some space on the
queenside this rook rook f5 don't have
one down bishop age six does not help
the MF night f7 it's not nothing at all
I DSC form navin it wasn't a good idea
anyway ok let's do this check oops I
didn't see that one cuz I gym what a sad
game sitting whoops foot step back what
is he doing here
can I get this pawn I shouldn't do it in
a way my time yeah I was actually trying
to do something instead of just play on
time as usual ah what a bad game on
offense on time yeah I mean it just
blundered blundered the pawn there on
the queenside and I shouldn't lose that
anymore I guess not sure maybe I'm still
lost but yeah it was of course I just
have to have to enter of course be
active with the night maybe even
blunders the Jeep on that I'm starting
to win and he played that one you know
you're playing for loss of course here
why does he why this verse yeah but the
whole game was of course really bad had
a really bad position the whole time
yeah it simply wasn't any good yeah
maybe maybe a five yeah why should I can
play ePHI here actually now maybe have
to do that and this passive passive kind
of defense was the the the ultimate
problem yeah of course this I saw that
but he can just take this and this is a
very one-sided position and that was so
I was somehow hoping to get the night
you know the night to a to e form we
just look trades let's say if I can get
the rooks off this is not so so terrible
but because my night is really having
some players don't get that in simply
don't I what a shame i was just one game
away from 25 and now too stupid losses
set you back too
set you back yeah okay just just a bad
game there thanks for watching